the story I have for you today is one
that is centered around a lost play now
it's not particularly bad that the play
is lost because as I recall it wasn't
particularly good but it's a play that I
wrote and I would have been around 11
years old when I wrote the play and when
it was actually per performed twice at
my school University Lake school out in
Heartland Wisconsin and the person who
spurred me to actually bring the play to
my Drama teacher was my dad and
unfortunately the play wasn't recorded
he tried to get there in time to see my
performance but he wasn't able to make
it but my mother was was able to be
there and so she could tell him all
about it now what kind of play was it
you could call it a mishmash of perhaps
sci-fi and fantasy acted out on the
stage with lots of opportunity for sword
fighting so some
choreography and how do you get into
this sort of thing so here's the
backstory in fifth grade at Wales
Elementary I read my first book of Lloyd
Alexander's pridan or pran Chronicles
however it's supposed to be pronounced
which is drawing on Welsh mythology and
legends and telling this wonderful
fantasy tale that is aimed at you know
children but can be profitably reread as
I did later on by
adults and I read the fifth book which I
found in our library and I was just
fascinated by it it had all the sort of
elements that I already liked from say
The Hobbit or fantasy stuff that I was
seeing on TV or in comic books or other
stories and actually by that time we'd
already had The Lion The Witch in the
wardrobe read to us I remember reading
some of the
other uh Narnia books as well though not
the entire series much of that would
have to wait until middle school as well
so I read this first book The High King
which was awesome and I didn't quite
understand everything that was going on
in it in part because there was this
backstory of other books in it but then
I was able to go back and start I kind
of read them in a halfhazard manner as I
recall I think the next one that I read
was the Black Cauldron which is the
second book in the series and the main
character although there are a couple
other really important characters
there's a guy named Taran and he is a
foundling who will go on to become a
great warrior and become the high king
of this this land after he conquers the
lord of the Dead Aran with the great
sword that has been stolen which
belonged to the actual King Gyan and
he's got a barred friend flutter flam
and there's a beautiful princess who's
also a tough girl herself uh from the
aisle of Lear eloi and there's a
nobody's quite sure exactly what he is
but a kind of hairy stinky guy named
gergy and there's others along the way
as well including uh the people who
bring up Taran uh and anyway long story
short I became fascinated with this and
in fifth grade in Wales Elementary uh
because I was considered gifted and
talented and because they had no idea
what to do with gifted and talented kids
they basically sent us off to do our own
thing they would say go to the library
and read some books and I don't know do
a report make up a project here's some
stuff that you can play with for science
class they often wouldn't include us in
the regular science class and they would
give us kits to play with for circuits
or you know biological things and there
was a gifted talented coordinator who
had come around every once a month or so
Mrs Bailey and uh you know we'd see her
for an hour and then that was it so
there was an awful lot of being left to
my own devices and I got really really
interested in among other things Lloyd
Alexander's pride and Chronicles five
books right and loved it and got a hold
of them and I would make maps and have
imaginary dialogues in my head and I
don't know where the idea first came to
me of writing a play but that's what I
did now was it a play that was very
faithful to the source material no
because what I did have is a bunch of
kids from the present day finding what I
called the time machine but it was less
of a time machine and more of a let's
transport you to an alternate Dimension
machine
that they step through and it it's never
very well explained it's more like a
portal than a machine because there's no
buttons or anything and they go through
and now they're in this Kingdom and so
you know this sort of Trope has been
done a lot right and in the 1970s were
were full of stories like this and you
know even some good fantasy is like that
think about the complete enchanter
series by uh Fletcher Pratt and elre to
Camp uh done much better than this sort
of thing that I was doing but in any
case I started writing a
play and in the play a lot of things
happen Aran is there who's the lord of
the dead and he's kind of a Darth Vader
character I think I a lot of us had Star
Wars on the mind and uh you know same
sort of thing dressed in black Larger
than Life scary evil threatening uh
wants to kill all the other uh
characters or you put them in prison
take them to the Land of the Dead and um
you know there was elino in it and I
don't remember exactly who else I had I
didn't have the full cast and then
there's these people who come from the
present now I started working on this
before I I started sixth grade middle
school at University lak school and
there's a little bit of a story there as
well I'll tell it to you very quickly
because I've mentioned it in other
places so I went to a uh Public
elementary school and we lived out in
the countryside so it was pretty rural
as I mentioned there was a gifted
talented program for the kids who were
smart but it wasn't it wasn't even a
program it was more like you guys go
over there and do your thing you know
stay out of our our hair and it was a
pretty rough Place Kettle Marine now
it's a great School District back then
it was pretty low down and uh you know
you you had a chance to get bullied and
beaten up and there were a lot of tough
kids and what they wanted to do with me
was move me from fifth grade right into
seventh grade and I was like oh that's
going to be terrible I'm going to get my
butt kicked every single day by these
bigger kids because they don't like
smart kids anyway so my parents looked
around and they found this private
middle school and it just so happened
because of my test scores I qualified
for a scholarship which is the only way
that we could afford for me to go there
and there were some other kids there
like me as well my good good friend uh
John and my good friend Steve they were
all scholarship kids as well and I'll
say this about yous in general you were
smart or you were rich and there wasn't
much intersection between those two
classes and I think frankly that the
reason why uh we scholarship kids were
there was to bring up the average test
scores so it look better to uh people on
on the outside and some of these rich
kids were like super rich we'd actually
have a state senator who would come and
meet with the students and why would
they do that because their parents were
big contributors so I you know I was
just a kid wearing uh clothes that my
mom seed at home or uh cheap tough skins
and and you know uh whatever happened to
be the case I didn't go uh downhill
skiing like these kids and that was the
way it was for for uh my friend as well
but you know there were some good kids
in with these rich kids as well and one
of the really cool things about this
school was that drama was part of the
curriculum it was not an option it was
not like you have the drama nerds over
there the theater kids and then
everybody else does their thing every
single student in sixth and seventh and
maybe even eighth grade and I don't know
what it was like for high school CU I
didn't go there for high school every
single student took drama and the
classes were small all of us sixth
graders were actually in one class there
were about 25 of us and we were a class
that only had four girls so it's almost
all boys and a few girls the other
classes were a little bit more even that
way which worked out good for the play
because I didn't have an awful lot of
female characters so uh every week drama
class you know we had to do skits we had
to do improvisational things we had to
work on uh how to use our bodies and um
you know read lines and things like that
and it was with Mrs badale uh who was
the Drama teacher and also an English
teacher as I had in I think a seventh or
eighth grade and um she was married to a
guy who was an English teacher as well
so long story short I'm writing this
play and working on it up in my
bedroom and I it's not really ready for
prime time and I'm I'm a little bit
embarrassed to show it to anybody and so
what I would do is I would shove it into
my desk
drawer so one day my dad who was very
very hard worker um he was a tax
attorney worked here in Milwaukee at
that time an hour commute away on on a
good day from where we lived way out in
the sticks in in on the border of Del
field in Wales and he happened to be so
you know we had a two-story house and
you'd go up the stairs and it was kind
of like a horseshoe landing and my
parents room was over there and his den
was over there until Grandpa moved in
and then had that as his room my
sister's room was at one end of the
Horseshoe and my room was at the other
so my dad poked his head in and he saw
me shoving these papers into a desk
drawer and then he was you know he he he
was like well what is that and I didn't
want to show him and I did show him and
I could see him reading it and I was you
know kind of worried because I thought
well he's a smart guy um very
accomplished um he's going to think this
is crap so he's reading it and I
remember this very vividly seeing him
with this furrowed expression reading
through it page after page after page
and then he said to me and he wasn't
smiling you're G to show this to your
teacher and I was like oh crap so now he
doesn't like it and he thinks I'm
wasting my time trying to write plays
and he's going to make me show it to my
teacher and who knows what she's going
to think of it she's probably going to
think it's garbage too maybe she'll
laugh at me I'll get punished in some
way for this this is terrible right what
I didn't know is that he actually
thought it was really good and he was I
suppose you could call it tough life of
some sort and so he was um you know
making sure that it would actually get
to to them and if I remember right he he
said you have to finish this and then um
I didn't end up taking it to the teacher
he ended up taking it to the teacher I
don't know how this scheduling worked
out but he drove in and met with her
and then um you know the next time we
had class
Mrs badale said well we have uh somebody
who's written a play here it's Greg over
there and it's quite good you know for
for a student work uh you know and I was
a sixth grader what the hell did I know
and she said we're gonna put this play
on and she didn't say do you think we
should put this play on she didn't leave
it up to the students she said this is
the play that we are doing for this
semester because every semester we would
have to do a play there were there were
actually two plays there was a play in
the class and then there would also be
like a middle school play that you could
try out for I never did any of those
that would that actually was for the
drama theater uh people who who you know
did that more and you know in part I
didn't do that because it meant like
additional time that I'd have to spend
at uls and it was already enough but
every class
we were rehearsing this place so we had
to figure out who's going to be who and
because we had so many students and
there weren't that many roles in the
play Mrs badale said all right we're
doing two Productions of this so
production a production
B and as I mentioned there was lots of
room for sword fights in it and now part
of this again I got to tell a little
backstory I was in Cub Scouts and if you
don't know about Cub Scouts it's sort of
like the Jew Junior thing for the Boy
Scouts and um every month there's like a
theme like it could be uh making cars
that you know race down these things or
shooting off model rockets or it could
be like learning how to walk in the
woods or cooking or stuff like that and
I think it was in either fourth grade or
fifth grade it was nights and so what we
did is we all made like wooden swords or
other cool things like some people would
you know make like a ball and chain with
a a sock and a ball in it and a stick
and they they'd spray paint it silver
and uh we made like Shields and we
learned about heraldry and painted the
Shields and some of us had potato chip
um um what would you call them like they
they were these cylindric containers I
guess you'd say boxes and they were just
the right size you're putting on a kid's
head if you put a little padding in
there so we made helmets and we had
armor that we kind of made up and it was
so cool and the best thing about it was
once we were done with like the official
stuff for the pack you had packs and
then um dens dens were the the smaller
group like a squad size and then like a
company size
so all of us kids started like having
fights with each other hitting each
other with our swords you know the
Shields and stuff like that this is the
kind of stuff that we did in our
neighborhood anyway we would get sticks
and try to hit each other and we' get
like garbage canned Lids you know the
old metal ones and we'd bang on each
other and so we were all into this sort
of thing so for me this play was partly
a way to do homage to Lloyd Alexander
and his wonderful pran Chronicles but it
was also an excuse to do the kind of
crap that I love doing anyway you know
I'd seen Zoro and the Three Musketeers I
wanted to be a sword fighter that was
one of the things I I had in mind at the
time so anyway um we go through
production and you know I have to do a
couple like you know rewriting little
parts of it Mrs badale was very helpful
with it uh giving suggestions about how
the play could be improved and we do the
scenery and we start making costumes and
we start making wooden
swords except for one Boy George whose
dad actually owned a
Foundry George came to class with a
metal sword now it wasn't sharp but it
was it was definitely a metal sword it
was heavy as hell and it was so cool
right so you know the other thing I'll
tell you about sword stuff so my uncle
aay uh who you may have heard about in
some of my other stories one of my
favorite uncles really cool guy
struggled with bipolar disorder severe
bolar disorder his entire life um and he
he lived with my grandparents for a long
time and he had a wood shop in the
basement and aim was an amazing
woodworker and Carver the sorts of
things that he could do with wood and
tell you about it were just amazing he
also started me carving he encouraged me
and my sister bought us knives at
Christmas showed us how to use them how
to use uh a chisel how to use all the
other kinds of tools to make beautiful
things out of wood he also taught me how
to do carpentry you know put up a stud
wall and stuff like that anyway aim
decided that he was going to make me a
scimitar a scimitar is a curved
sword and um he did it he he had a saw
he got some good wood he made me this
thing we painted it silver I brought it
to class and everyone's like holy crap
that is a sword that's amazing right now
I up breaking it getting in a sword
fight with George broke it off at the
thing and had to like stick it back in
with some screws and stuff so it didn't
look quite the way it was supposed to by
the way guess which character I was I
didn't play the hero in my uh particular
production I was Arwin the lord of the
dead the big baddy and so I got to do
lots of sword fighting of course that
was one of the reasons I wanted that
role Mrs badale let me pick which role I
wanted cuz it was my play right and then
she directed all of it so weeks and
weeks and weeks and weeks of rehearsal
and preparation and getting the S uh
scenes ready and then telling all the
parents okay the play is going to be put
on after school at this time show up
you'll get to see your sons and
daughters doing their thing in drama
class and of course my my dad uh you
know he had to work in Milwaukee and he
tried to get off but he wasn't a partner
he was he was in tou Ross which was at
that time one of the uh fastest
expanding um tax accountancy legal um
entities they were gobbling up all these
other and so he was kind of he was you
know up but also down in the food chain
as they say so he he couldn't get off
and I'm you I'm watching and our play
went on First and my mom is there my
sister is there and um you know we we
acted out my dad isn't there and I'm I'm
like ah crap you know he's not going to
see it and of course they had video
recorders at the time but nobody was
video recording it and then he uh he
came in just as the second
production was going on was you know in
process so he got to see a bit of it but
he didn't get to see me doing that and
um you know he he did the best he could
and uh he was the one who who was the
Catalyst for the play not existing but
getting put on in the first place so you
know this is kind of a a cool thing I
never actually did write another play
after that I don't maybe I'll do that
someday instead the playwriting acting
whatever you want to call it fog got
passed down to one of my children my
oldest child cat who is um going to
graduate fairly soon from the theater
program here in Milwaukee at University
of Wisconsin Milwaukee and cat has been
in a number of plays but also has
written plays way more than I have and
way better than I have as well and has
uh interest and talent for stage combat
as well so it's kind of cool to see how
these things don't don't necessarily
just stop and disappear and I think of
my my dad was still around unfortunately
he died when he was only 36 and actually
that that summer uh between sixth and
seventh grade for me that was the last
year that was the last opportunity I
think he would have been very proud to
see um what cat is doing with with
theater and that would be uh quite quite
cool so uh long story uh it looks like
it's uh you well over 20 minutes about
this play that got put on once it's lost
I don't know where the manuscript is
we've moved so many times and so much
has been lost uh over the course of all
of these shifting around maybe my mom
had it somewhere but unfortunately she
died in 2000 so you know it's it's long
gone except perhaps in the glimmer of
memory of some people and in your
imagination as I'm telling you its story
here